serological pipettes are used for  transferring milliliter volumes of  liquid and are commonly used with an  electronic pipette dispenser our  serological pipette tips have  graduations to help you accurately  aspirate or dispense liquid and is  individually wrapped to help keep it  sterile our serological pipette tips are  calibrated for accuracy dispensing to  within plus or minus two percent our  serological pipette tips are produced  from Crystal Clear polystyrene and are  color coded for easy volume  identification it also includes a  filtered plug for preventing both liquid  and aerosols from contaminating the  pipetters when you finish dispensing  liquid from a serological pipette it is  normal to have a little bit of residual  volume at the tip this is accounted for  in the volume graduations